mais je dois continuer à marcher le long de la route. »
Le long de la route.
Merci infiniment.
(Applaudissements)
Comment vous vous sentez ?
Fantastique.
Pouvez-vous chanter avec moi juste pour une seconde ?
Pourriez-vous chanter quelque chose ? Chanter un ré ?
Chantez « Oh »!
(Public bourdonne)
Oh -- plut fort, plut fort.
(En chantant) Oh.
Maintenant, s'il vous plait, si vous pouvez chanter,
chantez « Oh oh oh. »
Le public : Oh oh oh.
Jacob Collier : Whoa oh oh.
Public : Whoa oh oh.
JC : Whoa oh.
Public : Whoa oh.
JC : Dites « oh oh oh ».
Public : Oh oh oh.
JC : Whoa oh oh.
Public : Whoa oh oh.
JC : Chantez « Whoa oh oh. »
JC : Whoa oh oh.
Public : Whoa oh oh.
Merci infiniment. C'est beau. Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Donc, vous sentez le mouvement ?
Faire partie de ce mouvement,
des choses se déplaçant sous la surface ?
Donc, le langage de l'harmonie musicale est extraordinaire.
C'est une manière de naviguer sa palette d'émotions.
mais sans dire un mot.
Et je pense, comme c'est le cas avec beaucoup d'autres langues,
peu importe ce qu'on connaît d'une langue,
combien de mots, de phrases, on connaît.
Ce qui importe ce sont les choix émotionnels
que tu fais avec cette langue.
J'encourage à accueillir cette idée en tant que communauté,
qui est ce qui pourrait nous faire évoluer dans le temps
à l'opposé de ce qui nous éloigne de notre humanité.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)
(En chantant) Emmène-moi
n'importe où tu veux aller.
Tu sais que mon amour est fort.
Dans mon refuge,
Doucement,
comme le calme après la tempête,
Trouve ce que j'ai toujours cherché.
Dans mon refuge.
Même quand je ferme les yeux,
ma chérie, si tu t'es égarée, je suis en route vers mon refuge.
Touche-moi
comme si je n'avais jamais aimé,
dans l’endroit que j'adore,
dans mon refuge.
Je sais
quel que soit le sens du souffle du vent
il y aura toujours un endroit où je pourrai aller
dans mon refuge.
Mon refuge.
Bâtons et pierres.
Je ne me cacherai plus de toi.
Et au bon moment,
je trouve ce que j'ai longtemps cherché.
J'ai entendu ta voix
qui m'appelle.
Je suis en route
vers où je peux être libre.
Et si elle ne m'attend pas, fais-le bien, sans te retourner,
garde mon cœur dans le futur.
Sur les semelles de mes chaussures tous les lieux où j'ai été,
que j'ai connus depuis que je l'ai connue.
Car c'est toi, ne sais-tu pas que tu me fais croire
que tu es la seule pour moi.
Que c'est toi, j'imagine, que j'ai toujours voulu connaitre.
Femme, c'est toi que je veux, qui me complète.
Car tu es celle qu'il me faut.
C'est grâce à toi, j'imagine, que je veux que tu sois celle à qui j'appartiens.
Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup. Merci.
Merci.
Merci infiniment. Merci à vous.
Kelly Stoetzel : OK, Jacob. Waouh !
OK, nous avons quelques questions. JC : OK.
KS : C'était spectaculaire.
JC : Merci, Kelly. Merci.
KS : Ces visuels que nous venons de voir,
se passaient en temps réel, n'est-ce pas ?
JC : Oui, tout ce qui est visuel
répond aux choses auditives, ou quelque chose, s'il s'agit d'un mot,
donc tout est en temps réel.
Je cale les boucles, je joue les instruments
et puis, par exemple, l'arbre que vous avez vu pousser,
il grandit en prenant des notes basses et longues
et il pousse des branches longues et épaisses,
et il prend des notes hautes et tranquilles, peu importe,
et il fait pousser des branches fines et petites.
Et puis ma voix chante,
comme en soufflant du vent contre l'arbre.
KS : Donc tu as 22 ans. JC : Oui, en effet.
KS : Tu as joué tout cela tout seul.
Comment as-tu commencé et évolué ?
JC : J'ai une chambre magique à la maison
au nord de Londres, par là-bas.
Merci de représenter le nord de Londres.
Et cette pièce... Enfin, c'est la maison de famille.
J'ai grandi dans cette pièce remplie d’instruments de musique.
Mais le plus important, j'ai une famille
qui m'a encouragé à utiliser mon imagination,
donc ce que j'ai créé, ce que j'ai construit,
étaient les bonnes choses à faire
juste parce que je les faisais
et je pense que c'est une idée très importante.
Cette pièce était mon paradis
et en faisant la tournée de l'album appelé « Dans ma chambre »,
j'ai pensé amener ma chambre en tournée.
C'est une idée un peu bizarre,
mais j'y ai travaillé pendant quelques années
et c'est plutôt excitant d’être à l’intérieur du cercle.
KS : Donc c'est vraiment aménagé comme dans ta chambre ici.
JC : C'est un peu ça. C'est similaire à ma chambre
car je peux créer des choses dans l'instant et être spontané,
ce qui pour moi est l'essence même de la musique et de toute bonne idée.
KS : Donc tu as gagné deux Grammys
pour un enregistrement que tu as fait tout seul dans ta chambre.
Comment est-ce possible ? On n'aurait pas pu faire cela,
cela n'aurait pas pu arriver il y a cinq ans seulement.
JC : C'est un monde tout nouveau.
Le pouvoir est maintenant aux mains du créateur,
je sais que vous êtes d'accord,
par opposition à la grosse maison de disques
ou au grand patron.
Quelqu'un avec une bonne idée.
A TED, vous le savez déjà,
mais quelqu'un avec une idée peut planter cette graine.
C'est la personne qui apporte la lumière au monde.
Et oui, j'ai fait cet album complétement seul
et je n'ai pas attendu que quelqu'un me dise :
«Tu devrais faire un album tout seul. »
Je me suis lancé et je l'ai fait
sans me soucier de l'opinion des autres.
Et deux Grammys, c'est un sacré bonus.
(Applaudissements)
KS : Merci beaucoup, Jacob. JC : Merci Kelly. Merci beaucoup.